now listen up soldiers look alive this
is Vietnam War 4 and the commies are on
the move our objective nav is simple we
need to put down the commies command we
destabilize the region enough will draw
them out he'll show a stamp face and all
we have to do is locate and terminate so
corporal Colt and corporal colt listen
up chances of survival on this campaign
would normally be slammed with your
father was Rex power coal treating the
best I'm Cyber Command don't ever walk
the earth yeah this is the sort of thing
you've both been born and enhance to do
Roxanne General Sir later yes Vietnam is
just the tip of the iceberg this war is
big the Communists are spread like a
peanut butter while fire first we hit
miami this place is juan comi cesspool
more heat guns and back in the 80s we
need to shut down their supply line
right at the source the Gorbals don't
sample the merchandise Japan shouldn't
be a problem for you you played so many
of those video games you can handle all
the neon lights and giant listen take
your throw edge are you ready but I have
a feeling it's not going to be
straightforward after that we'll be
going into space where we fight the CIA
that's right the Communists insectoid
aliens the result of interstellar
crossbreeding between the commies and
alien bugs this war is over 50 yard
bonneville mess corporals and
it's ours to clean up be prepared for
anything cuz this is gonna be hell do
you copy soldier good take it to the rec
stream
you